a top executive of Chinese telecom giant
Huawei will have a bail hearing in
Canada later today amid new tensions
between Beijing and Washington she could
be sent to the US to face criminal
charges
now her arrest is adding to Wall
Street's fear that the trade showdown
with China is escalating senior foreign
affairs correspondent face nation
moderator mark Brennan is in Washington
Margaux good morning good morning Nora
this arrest is extraordinary Huawei is
the largest telecom equipment maker in
the world it sells more phones than
Apple
so the Trump administration's decision
to extradite one of its top executives
shocked the markets and Beijing we will
always follow the advice of our national
security and intelligence community at
the request of the Trump Justice
Department Canadian authorities arrested
Huawei executive hmong wong jo while she
changed planes at Vancouver Airport
Hmong is Huawei's chief financial
officer and daughter of the company's
founder neither the u.s. nor Canada has
given a reason for the arrest but it
comes amid a probe of suspected
violations of US sanctions it's a
dramatic step to pull somebody off an
airplane former State Department
official James Lewis said US officials
also suspect Huawei of using its
technology to help the Chinese
government spy the CIA the FBI NSA have
been worried about Huawei for years and
years on Thursday Huawei denied any
wrongdoing and Beijing demanded mum's
immediate release Republican Senator
Marco Rubio said the company is a threat
to American business and national
security they're an instrument that they
use to spy and to steal intellectual
property and while defending America's
dominance in the tech industry is at the
heart of president Trump's trade dispute
with China the White House insists that
he had no idea the arrest was about to
take place on Saturday when he began
brokering a trade truce with China's
leader Xi Jinping helped them still seek
Mike Pillsbury is an outside adviser to
the Trump administration whatever this
telecom executive was doing does should
we assume the Chinese government knew
about it well somebody in the Chinese
government almost certainly knew about
it President Xi
as another story the White House insists
that the timing was coincidental but
National Security Advisor John Bolton
also said that stopping Huawei and other
companies from stealing American
intellectual property must be part of
any future trade deal with China this of
course will be topic on Face the Nation
Sunday with Republican senators Marco
Rubio and John Thune viana Margaret
thank you of course Washington will be
watching closely as well Wall Street